earlier tonight during the State of the
Union address the president announced a
second meeting with North Korean leader
Kim jong-un it'll be in Vietnam let's
take a look as part of a bold new
diplomacy we continue our historic push
for peace on the Korean Peninsula our
hostages have come home nuclear testing
has stopped and there has not been a
missile launch in more than 15 months if
I had not been elected president of the
United States we would right now in my
opinion be in a major war with North
Korea much work remains to be done but
my relationship with Kim jong-un is a
good one
chairman Kim and I will meet again on
February 27th and 28th in Vietnam
joining us now with more South Carolina
Senator Lindsey Graham I was at the
first summit in Singapore right 15
months no rockets fired the remains of
Americans from the 50s of return
hostages have been returned the
president has given nothing and we are
talking about the D nuclearization of
the entire Korean Peninsula sounds
pretty promising to me and hopeful what
do those people are criticizing the
president how well did you do with
rocket man so yeah I'm very hopeful but
when meeting this new meeting will lead
to a breakthrough all right
overall preciseness why is he meeting
with Trump and he didn't meet with
anybody else
interesting maybe believes that he's
serious I think he's scared do you tell
what spoke on well okay if you want to
get this guy's attention he's not like
Iran Iran's on a religious mission you
know if they ever get nukes oh use them
this guy is trying to have an insurance
policy to keep the Mafia state going but
if Trump gives them an alternative
between life without nuclear weapons
that is safe and secure he'll take it if
the other alternative is to lose your
life the thing that stood out the most
more than anything that I'm so happy
about the Taliban
at the table it's a great point
I know I think you'll tell us why I've
been going there I've asked your own
questions I like interviewing me I've
been there 52 times and we are they're
talking with us now because when the
first day he got in office he told the
military kicked their ass we've been
killing these guys by the thousands
we've been breaking their back in
Pakistan for the very first time in a
decade is beginning to help us on their
side of the border because Trump has
really unleashed the military they're at
the table now because of the change in
the rules of engagement after Obama left
Trump came in and there at the table and
we may be able to win this in this war
if Pakistan will help us and I predict
that the Prime Minister of Pakistan and
president Trump would get along very
well al Qaeda Afghanistan Iraq Syria
North Korea China were making progress
aquel realize the caliphate been
destroyed in about 18 months you ask
another great question I'm kelcie
unleash the military yes he did see
Obama made it impossible to win Trump
has made it possible to win and we're
winning
I believe you hit on something profound
long we'll stay on national security
that is if they believe you that you
will do it that is one of the Europeans
now cracking down on the Iranians
because Trump gave them a choice you can
help me reign in this Iranian regime or
you will not have access to our economy
guess what they picked our economy over
the Ayatollah so add all of this foreign
policy success and I know you talked to
the president a lot safer you disagree
with him at times but you you make your
case you told me that he will you have
persuaded him unlike Obama he will
adjust his policies where it makes sense
he has unleashed the military on our
enemies is paying dividends he has
gotten out of a bad deal and I think he
would replace it with a better deal
we're more respected we're safer today
than we were two years ago and it's
because of this president let me go to
the economy so impressive I in 2016 for
me the election was about the Forgotten
men and women I actually bought the
original painting of this guy John
McNaughton right forgotten men and women
who
though the 13 million Americans on extra
Americans on food stamps 8 million more
in poverty worse recovery since the 40s
lowest homeownership rate 51 years the
debt more debt than 43 presidents
combined Louis labor participation 5.3
million new jobs since he's Alecto how
did all that happen Sean well I can tell
you because conservative economic
policies free-market capitalism
limited bureaucracy less government
intervention incentivizing businesses to
invest in factories manufacturing
centers it worked for Reagan it worked
for Kennedy and it's working for trying
to take everything he took and what
Obama did to suppress economic growth
and replaced it with pro-growth policies
he took all the fighting with the one
hand tied behind your back approach to
the war on terror and unleash the
military everything Obama did this guy's
doing opposite and it's working Lindsey
what I'm sorry senator actually a long
time we're not only Kevin I'll walk down
oh yeah listen I think you had your a
career moment that saved that nomination
and thank you for doing that how many
times have you heard a president say at
the State of the Union what the Virginia
governor said was an American Wow
so okay you haven't all walks down you
got more money in your pocket your
country stronger than ever we're going
to win and when you say we're not a
socialist country they couldn't stand up
only chuck it Nancy did they didn't know
what to do road to the nomination for
the Democratic Party runs to Venezuela
all right you had to prepare that and
think about that all day I want to go to
immigration and I was asking Santa Cruz
your colleague moments ago look it looks
like president's gonna have to go alone
here's my fear and you addressed it this
week yeah there might be a number of
your colleagues I cannot support them
there's too many drugs too much death
too many assaults to any angel of moms
and dads that I met in my life will
these Republicans step up and support
securing our border for the safety
security its life and death for the
American people here's the question I
would ask any Republican senator
remember the house do you disagree with
the
that said about the state of the border
do you disagree with the the drug
analysis you disagree with the human
trafficking problem do you disagree with
the threats coming through the border if
you agree with him then have the courage
to do something your Republican
colleagues do what is right they will
that people like you remind them along
reminding you I'm going to put pictures
that will help so I love all of my
colleagues but this president if he gets
a dollar for the wall from Nancy's got
to do it himself now after this speech
do you have any doubt that he will do it
if he has to alone I've known him for 10
years I know
so to my Republican friends that get on
the train too so if you're the president
how do you not secure the border after
that speech he's tenacious he's
unrelenting and I know you've been a
become a good friend of his good to be
thank you for stopping by know your
success appreciate it that's right thank
God